اعلنت هيئه النزاهه في العراق عن صدور
اوامر قبض وتحر بحق اربعه من كبار
المسؤولين في حكومه رئيس الوزراء السابق
مصطفى الكاظمي وذلك بتهمه تسهيل الاستيلاء
على مبالغ الامانات الضريبيه
وقالت الهيئه في بيان ان الاوامر القضائيه
صدرت بحق كل من وزير الماليه ومدير مكتب
رئيس الوزراء
والسكرتير الشخصي لرئيس الوزراء والمستشار
الاعلامي لرئيس الوزراء في الحكومه
السابقه واكدت صدور اوامر بحجز او اموالهم
المنقوله وغير المنقوله
معنى من بغداد مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
ابراهيم ووليد نستمع منك الى مزيد من
التفاصيل
عثمان هذه ليست المره الاولى التي تصدر
منها
مثل هذه الاوامر اوامر
استقدام او اعتقال لكنها قد تكون هذه
الابرز في سلسله طويله من من هكذا عمليات
حدثت في الشهرين او في الثلاثه اشهر
الماضيه لانها فقط ان نذكر ان قبل ايام
اصدرت هيئه النزاهه العراقيه بيانا قالت
انها اصدرت اوامر قبض واستقدام بحق تسعين
من ممن وصفتهم كبار المسؤولين العراقيين
السابقين والحاليين في هذه
من هؤلاء التسعون كما تقول هيئه النزاهه
هناك وزراء سابقون هناك نواب حاليون ونواب
سابقون هناك محافظون سابقون ونواب حاليون
وهناك العديد العديد من كبار المسؤولين
ممن يحتلون مناصب رفيعه في الدوله
العراقيه اقول هذه ليست المره الاولى
لكنها قد تكون الابرز لانها طالت شخصيه
رفيعه مثل وزير الماليه السابق وهو عبد
الامير علاوي رغم ان عبد الامير علاوي كان
اول من تحدث عن هذه الفضيحه عن هذه السرقه
التي باتت تعرف بالعراق بانها سرقه القرن
وهي سرقه مبلغ يقترب من اثنين ونصف مليار
دولار من اموال ضريبيه لشركات اجنبيه
عامله بالعراق كانت موجوده في حساب لدى
دائره الضريبه التابعه لوزاره الماليه هذا
المسعى هو جزء من تعهد ايضا عثمان اطلقه
رئيس الوزراء عندما تسلم مسؤولياته في
برنامجه الحكومي هو تعهد بمحاربه الفساد
ورئيس الوزراء العراقي الحالي محمد شياع
السوداني اكد في اكثر من مناسبه ان عمليه
محاربه الفساد هذه المره لن تقف عند حدود
القاء القبض او او او اصدار احكام قضائيه
ضد المتهمين لكنها ايضا ستكون عمليه
استعاده ما تم سرقته من اموال السلطات
العراقيه كانت قد اعلنت في الفتره الماضيه
انها سعاده بضعه او عدد من المئات
المليارات في هذه القضيه تحديدا وبكل
التاكيد المبلغ الذي تم استعادته لا يشكل
سوى جزء ضئيل مما كان قد سرق اقول ان هذه
ان هذا المساء يعكس حرص حكومه رئيس
الوزراء الحالي على محاربه الفساد ورئيس
الوزراء العراقي قال ان العراق لن يتردد
في التعامل مع الانترنت في عمليه استعاده
المسؤولين الذين كانوا قد هربوا الى خارج
العراق في هذا الاطار شكرا جزيلا لك مدير
مكتب الجزيره في بغداد وليد ابراهيم